yeah I know what's bad milk tastes like
especially you've been broke all your
life we're eating flavor almonds you're
like um I mean like I don't hate it
I like salted cashews yeah those are
good I eat almonds every day you do I do
or like fun hell yeah especially almond
joy yeah you darling well I'm not like
obsessed with it they seem like a
healthy alternative
I like almond milk but I don't really
eat almonds as nuts you're not gonna
like this here we have honey butter
which sounds amazing
I don't like honey that much really
you're weird here we let me look at home
sugar this head morning grandma oh one
grandma sugar that's not bad
here we go okay I thinks I can be okay I
could actually have this like all the
time what are you making that face for I
was not expecting this haste originally
it tasted like a mix of honey and butter
and then suddenly had this kind of like
cheese after tape maybe because I don't
like honey but it's very deep what's
wrong yes it's red into your mouth why
it tastes sugar is oh honey honey is
sweet have you never heard of honey
being sweet asabi
i love wasabi when you eat sushi I
scooped it like it's green tea ice cream
it's like ice could be like this much
like a bacon yeah
oh how know with the miniguns we don't
you spike ceiling I'm excited about this
I feel like this is a new way to eat
wasabi other than wasabi peas and sushi
it smells like a really good like Korean
junk food one time I had my little
brother try wasabi and told him that it
was guacamole Oh delicious mmm I love it
it's really good perfect amount of spice
yeah like wasabi peas are we spicier
that says if he's really good
there's a kick that's a kick ain't it a
phrase you like that it's not that bad
boom it's like wasabi peas but actually
a little bit better because I prefer
almonds over P I thought I would hate it
cuz like I only eat wasabi with sushi
oh no I'm into this it wasn't spicy it
wasn't straight like there was a eat in
and the heat is what you won't got
something I could eat this every day
mmm your Gerdes or more known as yeah
cool
yeah cold it's like Bama Tunisia I think
Japan and Korea mostly drinkable yogurt
but it tastes really good
I'm trying to figure it out it tastes
like fruit loops milk it tastes like the
milk like the milk is expired the milk
is expired yeah it's a little
questionable it is exactly like Yakult
with Alan right bottom like they should
go together yeah it tastes like a little
bit expired
yeah it just is like expired meal it's
like you dip an almond when you're cold
and you like sit there for like two
hours it's right it dry it up and you
eat it
I love wasabi sabi sabi was by far the
best I would eat that daily I like that
you have everyone maybe I like expired
milk someone's got it have it this one's
not too sugary is the different isn't it
partakes it's like a little different I
didn't think the wasabi was disgusting
her hideous or nothing like that it was
just a kick because my taste buds are
not used to like anything spicy or any
heat gonna be healthy and still have a
taste
yeah you got it I'll eat the yogurt one
reminds me of my broke chopper
[Music]